hello and welcome to this video playing
FSM 666 FSM okay it's a long one okay
I'm a short game probably the wrong
opening to have a short game but if I
win a long one I'm also fine I
definitely want to win this if it my
rating is below 2,400 I really feel like
something's completely wrong what's
going on there King g8 all of a sudden
yeah I'm not sure why teen jade was
necessary okay is it an idea to take
with the Queen I mean it definitely is
an idea yeah but this is far more far
more normal just take with the night
yeah yeah that's a kind of move why you
immediately see that it's not good but
how do you refute it then that cannot be
a good move simply because of the
weakness of d5 I mean here he has to go
with it it's it's it's technically
already kind of tricky but strategically
it's also very bad so okay what to do
then he has to go Bishop e6 yeah
otherwise I simply take D aid and play
Knight c7 maybe a six as a move not
great but yeah so he's at the end going
for this okay I don't see a full
refutation let's say wouldn't be
surprised if there is one but I don't
see it something like this is definitely
good for white I don't know how good it
is you know yes it's kind of tough to
figure out the maximum you know this is
definitely good for white now you know
d5 is just very weak well he's got the
bad c8 Bishop also AM the bad c8 bishop
and it's not quite clear what his move
is really something like knight c6 if
everything else fails I can simply trade
this down to a to a really good ending
yeah I think I'm doing this it's a very
one-sided ending
I don't think it's it's not necessarily
the best way to play but it's super
one-sided he's stuck with the big pawns
a 6 e 6u v is also sticking out a little
bit yeah that's a move that one that did
the f3 is my next move anyway so Bishop
g4 is making no sense sorry if I'm so
harsh but it's just like what it is
f3 was my next move because I want to
get the king to e3 that's the ideal
square here for the King okay yeah yeah
that was also under on the agenda to
play Knight e4 so night--if form yeah I
I wonder I wonder if if I can play even
better here
rook t1 for example rock t1 would trade
at the end I have a knight on d1 well
there's no way he's not the one King f8
Knight 91 came
[Music]
I'm trying to figure out if I win the
win-win-win material by force on the on
the queenside
I might do but it's just like it's such
a luxury issue because this is this is
all way also possible of course like it
could be that rookie one just wins
immediately like if he has to take
everything there's a night on the one
and then night B to D three before and
so on it's extremely close to a flat-out
win so this is why I passed a moment
this is very good as well but here it's
not about very good teacher psychic can
you win the game immediately that's the
only task
the only task is for me that's the only
thing that would mean something actually
advantage you have in many ways such as
the fled our oh I didn't even notice
that he moved that's not a good thing
with down long time yeah he's got no way
to to save the pawn yeah I think taking
once it's not a bad idea and now you can
check on g1 it's probably useful it's
not quite clear if he has a good square
really yeah this is then we take a lot
of things yeah we should g8 yeah anyway
it's a good move a success hanging with
a huge check and Bishop g8 I have Luke
a7 I still have to be careful 28 seconds
is not a lot
I know it's counting no okay
it was a bit of a disaster right from
the opening yeah in fact I know it
sounds a bit weird but like this is not
a really good already because they're
attacked by concrete means it's a bit
tricky for black.this they normally play
knight c6 in this position but already
this is difficult if you check the form
black has to be very careful you not to
land into huge trouble in this position
what I often get is this which is a
disaster really Knight c3 Ruby one
coming that is not good at all
and he played King G aids and it's also
I think problematic it's just a
development that White has a development
advantage it's quite substantial so he
takes and now if a if v is just not a
good move I mean but maybe he doesn't
have anything better that's possible
right b5 looks like the right one a six
and the engine wants to play Knight 5 C
3 yeah it possible possible here a takes
B oops sorry not this one of course a
takes B is supposed to be a better
choice yeah I was I was wondering I
couldn't quite believe that um this is
good for black this is just not good but
it's probably better than the game again
was extremely one-sided yeah here this
is a moment where maybe taking it's not
the best move I'm not sure about it the
engine actually approves of it but it's
um you also would be better by something
like this where you get a tempo yeah
it's it's not a not so easy to give up
the great Bishop but you get into a
position that is so utterly one-sided
rook c1 Bishop Bishop g4 is just a bad
move I mean this is a move i play anyway
and Bishop f5 is also running into star
that I want to play like g4 later okay
here look to you one was even better
mmm-hmm yeah but it doesn't matter
really that is just a bad position
deform and interestingly the end
generates Bishop c2 as somewhat okay for
black and I find quite remarkable it
means that my move water wasn't right
there that I have to play this first you
know maybe you cannot save those pawns I
thought they'd move on I wouldn't matter
all that much but Bishop situation is a
good move brilliant I think the point is
that now this is not attacking all that
much and he's got f5 yet is indeed a key
that is indeed true I mean he's got he's
got to set dirham wow that's that's
remarkable Bishop c2 I didn't have on
the radar at all the difference is huge
I mean after this I'm just winning and I
mean I believe that my position is very
very much better here anyway so I didn't
really occur to me that there is an
opportunity for black Bishop c2 from
here black is basically lost him just
pick up pick up material
okay night c5 was better but it doesn't
really it doesn't really make a
difference here I would have would have
played look at seven I and the engine
approves him after a little bit of
thought oh okay six
yeah means two points up and I have an
attack and he I'm a piece up so it
doesn't winds quite quite clearly yeah
this is an remarkable case of a line
that looks fairly normal for black but
is indeed not that good okay guys thanks
for watching